foreign
[Music]
superintendent Shank
we need to know where he is look I know
he's in prison except he's not in prison
listen some Heroes wear capes some wear
coats and I know a lot has been made
about your code but I'm actually curious
I mean it's been a couple of years since
season five you're now in this film what
does it actually do for you as an actor
when you put that coat on I understand a
bigger budget you had 20 coats in this
filming this movie but what does it do
for you to put on the coat do you look
in the mirror do you sort of like
it definitely gives me a stance like I
put the coat on and I walk a certain way
you know what I mean like people go to
me Luther walk I'm like really little
walk
oh yeah because I sort of do this thing
on my shoulders and my hands in my
pocket it makes me move a certain way
but now it's really sort of like uh it's
a bit of a uniform I want to say that
you know I think the film gives us a
sort of new beginning and I want to
understand whether we can do a version
without the coat will he still be Luther
that is the I know a shock horror but
you know we started the film without the
coat and seems to still be him but then
when you see him in the car you're like
ah
so who knows we'll see what's your dream
wardrobe then for Luther if you could
put it out there and put him in anything
what are you putting them in well you
know I don't know it whatever it would
be he won't have a different costume
every day he's the kind of guy who's
going to wear the same shirt every day I
want to see him in Miami in like neon
neon whoa whoa whoa I mean Luther in
your shirt perhaps would be interesting
right that would be fascinating oh my
gosh I love it
um I knew you had a hand in casting Andy
Circus from what I understand it was
your suggestion and I'm wondering for
you what does it do for you playing
Luther when you're looking across David
versus Alice can you sort of compare and
contrast what they bring out I mean both
uh Andy and Ruth Wilson are just
phenomenal character actors actors full
stop that really embody and
you know if uh for me as an actor those
are the people that really raised my
game up to sort of you know but I'm also
like I'm equally as Idris fascinated in
Andean roof as Luther is in Alice and
David you know there's a real
Fascination to who they are and I think
that's what drives John is like
um I don't know why you're doing this
but I'm gonna find out I don't
understand what makes you tick and
that's something that I find so really
interesting to keep revisiting whenever
I play John Luther is like he needs to
get under the skin of the person he's
chasing and I know you've said in the
past you don't like to revisit
characters you obviously like to revisit
this one but obviously when you have a
film this time what I loved is seeing
Lutheran action and with I don't want to
spoil anything so maybe we could just
talk about it if you could do like a
little bit of a breakdown of the prison
breakout scene sort of what it demanded
of you you've joked before that playing
Luther isn't fun just because you're
cold it's usually demanding this took it
to another one yeah uh yeah I think you
know look in the TV show we didn't have
it didn't feel the quite sort of film
language or TV show language to have
these big fight action sequences he's
not an action star he's a policeman
right he's a you know but ultimately in
the film when we could broaden the lens
a little bit it felt really quite right
to see him get into some scuffles and
that's what I'm going to call the prison
scene for now it was a scuffle but it
really is designed with the aesthetic of
the show which is messy and Roar and
visceral and surprising you know I just
spoke to Neil and he told me because of
that little teaser at the end he already
knows where the series is going so what
was your reaction when he told you where
he wants to take it
um you know if I'm really honest
um I you know we sat down and huddled
and thought about where could It Go
and so
um I got a email and he showed me where
it was gonna go and I was blown like oh
I mean I that man needs a hug Neil he
needs a hug he needs some love in his
life because
I don't know where he gets it from do
you know what I mean oh he cooks up some
Darkness all right
because
that is who you are isn't it
congratulations on another amazing
villain you've created so many iconic
villains in your career from snoke and I
know Gollum there's there's a legend and
you've talked about it how when you were
creating the voice of Gollum the
inspiration was your cat coughing up a
furball so with this character with
David Roby I'd love to do like a little
bit of a breakdown into how you got into
this character sort of creating the
physicality of him from the great round
Bush bro blowout to the lenses to I know
you were singing The Supremes in the car
so if you could break down first the
physical aspects of how you became this
character so David is a very isolated
lonely individual who actually doesn't
exist in his own right and that is what
drives him in a way he he cannot
communicate he cannot connect with
Humanity the only way that he can really
connect is through voyeurism it's
through observing through through
people's devices in their own home by
watching them and he spends hour after
hour after hour watching people file
their nails pick their teeth floss their
teeth you know polish their shoes maybe
indulge in things that we can't talk
about on you know
uh but he basically sucks people's lives
out out of what he's and he's watching
all of these screens lots and lots and
lots of screens and then
you know for what they wear he has no
sense of style he doesn't know what he
what he should wear he he he only picks
items from what he sees and so it's like
a catalog it's like a it's like a it's
kind of Tinder swipe you know he's sort
of watching what's going on and then he
takes these things and and even the
hairstyle are completely inappropriate
with the rest of what he's wearing it's
all put together he's a he's a construct
he doesn't exist now I'm wondering who
he was spying on that gave him the hair
inspiration I'm like thinking like Barry
Manilow or something somebody said
seafood and Roy so that's not far off
actually but yeah Barry Manilow David
Soul uh you know he at one in one scene
and I don't want to give away the scene
but he has a kind of a hoodie on and I
mean this in the nicest possible way he
reminded me of a rat in a sewer and
there's a real duality of him right
there's that that sort of CEO vibe that
he gives but for you as an factor and I
know when you said when you read the
script it was like so dark you almost
didn't take the role so sort of that rat
like presence for you as an actor can
you talk about inhabiting that sort of
that character what you had to do to
shake it off at the end of the day yeah
I mean so so there's a there's a point
where he becomes this sort of his
version of a homeless person you know
and again it's everything's studied so
it doesn't it's not kind of it doesn't
he doesn't he doesn't climb into the
character he just he just he observes a
certain shape of some of how someone
carries themselves and then tries to
mimic it and doesn't quite pull it off
but so it's it's it's that that is and
so and that becomes his his way of being
able to be out in the open and be with
in in plain sight hiding in plain sight
through he's sort of like a he is like
an actor in a sense but I'm not a very
good one you know so so so
um so yeah that that whole thing of of
him embodying someone is is just learned
behavior it's my understanding that
Idris was the one that recommended you
for the role which I think is lovely so
I'm wondering for you this is such an
iconic character for him so when you are
in character and you are staring down at
your elbow and character what do you
think that he brings to the role that
makes this character endure and now have
its own film
I mean Idris is a phenomenal actor and
in this role that he has owned for 10
years I can only say being on set with
him and and I've always wanted to work
with him as well that's the other thing
are Parts have sort of crossed before
but but to be with him in this Zone
where you he he's so unpredictable as
the character but also Idris embodying
that character is is so unpredictable as
well and and so present and in the
moment it was very big sort of he he was
very magnetic as this role and it's just
great to see it go from from you know
what was an exceptional TV series to now
this big platform as a big movie you
know he he really owns it in a quite a
profound way I know you read the script
you said you had to shower afterwards
and almost didn't take the role so at
the end of each day or maybe at the end
of the raw how many showers were you
taking daily playing this role and can
you sort of talk about the physicality
because you and ninjas have this is a
bigger you know it's a film now it's a
bigger scope there's a lot of action so
sort of you know getting down and dirty
with with injurious and playing those
those physical scenes yeah I mean we had
we had a number of this flash points in
the movie where the two two characters
go head to head and the stunts were
there's some pretty visceral kind of
fighting that goes on but but also what
we wanted to work out was I mean Idris
is all about pure strength and muscle
and you know he's a kickboxer he's a
trained martial artist in real life
um we for David Roby again kind of
wanted something which was
passionless in a way in the way that he
fights it's sort of disassociated in a
way like he's he he he doesn't put
energy into it he sort of steps outside
of himself and watches himself fight and
so it's more like a
um with a minimum amount of effort it
sort of takes sucks energy out of people
that's all he does really is he sucks
energy out of people I am enjoying
myself
because I'm ready this was horrifying
terrifying most horror movies don't
scare me but this scares me and I think
the reason is and it's something that
you've touched on in the series
you are deepest fears as humans play out
in front of our eyes whether it's
somebody under our bed that goes back to
a childhood fear or in this case David
Roby where it's our deepest darkest
secrets are exposed and what would we do
to keep that secret so I'm wondering for
you Neil when you were writing this was
that something you sort of had in mind
like what would really scare somebody
and and do you think that it's going to
create a whole conversation about people
talking about well what would yours be
because as soon as the film ended I
thought oh my gosh if my own secret ever
was exposed what would I do what would I
have done in that situation so yeah
you're you are quite right but it's not
quite as grown up and professional and
calculated as you make it sound I'm the
world's most disorganized writer and all
I can write about is what frightens me
and the the idea that someone like David
Roby might be out there watching what I
do or my loved ones or my friends or my
colleagues I find quietly terrifying and
I understand you got the idea for it at
the end of season five yeah I was
walking um Jamie directed season five
and we are in some tumble down broken
derelict part of London in January and
it was very cold and I was going home
and I said goodbye to Jamie said goodbye
to the casting crew and I walked with
Idris to his trailer
and we were talking about
the movie as we often did when was the
time right and it's the time right now
after this show and as Idris opened his
trailer door
I went
he escaped prison to solve a crime uh so
that was when the idea came to me on the
set okay I'm gonna I'm gonna Circle back
to that at the end of this interview
um but Jamie for you I mean you're given
a little bit of a Netflix budget in this
one you're creating a film this is a
bigger thing you've shot in Piccadilly
Circus you went International you got to
shoot underground in a place apparently
you haven't nobody's seen since the 70s
so can you talk about there's such epic
scenes maybe particularly the Piccadilly
Circus scene and sort of just creating
just taking that what we love about
Luther and putting it on a much bigger
scale how thrilling was that for you as
a director and and how challenging was
that scene
extraordinary truly it was amazing I
mean the thing is you just hit the the
most important point is what we learn
about Luther in those moments because it
would be too uh easy to get lost in the
Maelstrom of the piece to forget the
very reason that we were there in the
first place I mean the thing is from
director I love television I'm directing
television for 20 years you have to do
all your work within a really
concentrated period of time all the prep
all the detail that goes into prep in a
really conflated uh place
um and then Netflix gave us this
resource to actually have all the tools
to prep a sequence like Piccadilly
Circus that we needed including virtual
cameras to enable me to stand in the
middle of Piggly circus and prep but
obviously I was in shepparton when I did
it
um I think it was extraordinary and it
really it was a great Gauntlet and it
said to you it said to me you know all
the stuff you've learned over 20 years
now you get to play but you get to play
understanding the the central most
important part of this sequence is John
Luther himself so all those extreme
roads lead back to that heart look it
was amazing I think I didn't realize in
my first feature-length story uh I'd get
chance to have fun in this sandpit with
a with an IP and a character that I
already love right you know so
um you know it was great I don't know
I'm running out of this is how I'm so
excited by the opportunity that this
gave me that I've run out of words
that's why it's great you've got Neil
cross sitting next to you well Neil I'm
going to circle back to what I asked you
before so at the end of this film since
you got inspired for this film from
season five at the end of this film it
sets up a whole new possibility for
Luther it's very cheeky that last scene
I was thrilled with it I was like oh my
gosh where could they go he's gonna he
could go fully International new job
opportunity do you already know do you
already have an idea
of where this is gonna go hey cheeky is
the best possible description of that I
think and be very much so yes